all right lee
lee uh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally originally from dayton
tennessee
right between nashville and chattanooga
and tell me about your family you had
both your parents when you were young
oh yeah i lost my mom whenever i was
nine i lost my dad whenever i was 17.
how would you describe your childhood
how would you describe your childhood
well we wouldn't we didn't have much we
were poor family
i wouldn't say completely poor but you
know
mostly the whole region is fairly poor
yeah mostly
black land farmers what they call them
what is a black land farmer
where they do farm work you know off and
on here and there for people
and uh any abuse any kind of craziness
in your childhood
none nothing and how far did you go in
school
i liked uh three weeks finished the
seventh grade
as far as you went yeah because this
past me on d's and else i never did do
that good in school anyhow i failed the
first grade
and i failed the sixth and not quitting
the seventh
well what did you do after that what did
you after that
well i went and uh registered for the
army but they turned me down because
they said i was cla
classified me as they but they never
went for my exam they classified me as
4f
and so after that i just whatever kind
of work
i could pick up that's what i've done
in other words i'm the
jack-of-all-trades and a master of none
and then uh do you have any any kids
ever married
yes i've been married twice i've got uh
three kids but uh i mean yeah two kids
by the first
wife i got one kid out of wedlock
that's mine and then i got uh
then i had my second marriage i had four
uh step daughters
and then at some point you got in
trouble with the with the law
yeah in 1984 uh
i see me and the old lady who had been
married for about me and my first wife
been married
about 14 15 years
uh let's see my first job with her was
born in
april of 72
74 and my son was born in 76
and after my son was born me and the
wife we didn't have sex or nothing
she cut me off completely i used to
drink a lot
i put that all down in 67 i weighed
97 really i put it all down
quit it all september the 21st of 97.
and uh
my wife she decided that one day she
wanted a divorce i told her i said well
whenever i married you i didn't marry to
give you no divorce
well i get it one way or the other and
so that's whenever i was accused of
messing with my daughter
and my niece and that's where i started
getting in trouble the law then
duis i had a few of them
because i used to drink a lot back years
ago
and just like i said i put it all down
97. i ain't touched it since
right and the the incidents with your
with the kids that was something that
actually happened or no she accused me
of it because she wanted a divorce
that's how she got her divorce
so you you claim it never happened nope
it never happened
i mean somebody did mess with my
daughter the fella
did mess with her he died
while i was locked up how many years in
prison did you do
i've done 30 uh 15 years in prison
19 years at arcadia at the uh
what you call it therapy
yeah therapy 19 years in there
so a total of 37
37 38 that have been locked up
and looking back at all that how do you
how do you
view all that do you feel like you just
got robbed or
well no i feel that i got cheated you
know
out of a marriage out of my kids i ain't
seen them since
84. i mean 37 years in prison it's rough
yeah
it is it sure is and for something you
you claim you were innocent of that yeah
makes it tough but just like i said the
fella that did mess with her
if she'd have said something to me i'd
have took care of it because i mean
that's the way i do
i take care of my family you know and uh
but then after i got locked up he ended
up
dying so i didn't have nothing to do
with that
right and what what emotions
does this all bring up for you you
struggle with like depression or anger
or
anxiety a little bit of both depression
anger i'm kind of like just like i said
i ain't seen my kids since
84. so
how was your relationship with your with
your daughter or with with the rest of
your family
well my daughter and my son we see we
got along good
i mean you know like a father and a
sister's father and kids should
my rest of my family we we were
close-knit
my sisters and brothers until i got in
trouble
and then whenever i went to prison they
all just seemed to
bury off i still talk to my baby sister
though once in a while i call her up and
talk to her so
she's the only one that i talk to and
you're
is it a daughter and a stepdaughter that
you it's my
daughter and my niece and your niece do
you have any
contact with them no none at all
none at all since that incident have you
spoken
nope never because just like i said i
hadn't seen them since 84. that's never
i got locked up i mean if if your niece
and daughter knew you were
not the not the predator you you'd think
they would have reached out to you at
some point
no they done what their mama said
because just like i said they were 10
year old
my daughter was and my niece was nine so
they got together my wife
my sister-in-law and my other
sister-in-law and
they come up that get a divorce
did they say in court that you were
guilty well i took a no contest
you know no contest plead because uh
i told my lawyer i said i don't want to
put my kids through any trouble i know
how these hero courts do them
they cross examine them and all this and
i said they're too young for that
so i went ahead and took a plea bargain
just like i said
i've done 15 years in prisons and
19 up there at arcadia and that there's
sexual
rehabilitating yeah and how how did you
how did you take to the therapy
[Music]
i made it through it yeah
what kind of things do they work on well
they work on your
attitudes your sexual
thoughts and things like that
and yet you had other yet another
marriage after this right
yes when you got out of prison well not
never got out of prison
well i got out and then i had to go back
on a violation of probation
but uh let's see my second marriage we
got married in
80 see 84.
no 80 uh 90.
about 90 90 91 and then we got divorced
in 92 never went back on the violation
of probation
what lesson has this all taught you ah
what have you learned from all of this
i'll learn to be careful who i mess with
very careful what are you doing now you
stay away from kids
yes
and do you have any friends today oh
yeah i've got a girlfriend now
i just think i was just with her a while
before you come
and looking back at your life do you
have any regrets
looking back at it yes i have regrets
because i mean
regret that i was accused of something
that i didn't do you know
what would you have done differently if
you if you could
well if i could go back and do things
over
i don't think i'd ever got married
just don't count the way the first wife
treated me
so because i was a virgin their men who
got married
and just like i said after my son was
born in 76
we didn't have sex but we was together
for about 15 years
14 15 years
all right lee well thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome and i
wish you
and your girlfriend the best of best of
luck well this year gal that i'm
lady that i'm going with i think she's
i think she's just a few years younger
than me she was born in 52 i think
or 53. so we seem to be
hitting it off pretty good good luck
with that oh yeah
all right thank you okay thank you
you